[Música]
cinco do dez de 1988
eu não sei o que essa data representa
pra vocês
só que é muito importante pra mim ea
data de nascimento
olha que coisa linda ela tem três fatos
curiosos também foi nessa data que a
constituição brasileira foi promulgada
por ulysses guimarães e por isso quase
minha mãe trocou meu nome de guilherme
polícias segundo fator curioso é que
quem nasce nessa data sabe que vai ser o
resto da vida um libriano com ascendente
em decisão
e terceiro porque ele foi nessa mesma
data que aconteceu uma aula exatamente
como essa que está na foto em alguma
universidade de um professor que tinha
alunos estudando 30 anos se passaram até
o dia de hoje eu aposto que você com
vocês
se a gente sair daqui hoje e buscar uma
aula acadêmica acontecendo
o retrato vai ser esse exatamente igual
ao que a gente viu há 30 anos
sala de aula cheia de tijolos aulas
presenciais e teóricas professores
tentando passar conhecimento alunos
sendo receptores de conteúdo prova sendo
aplicados para reprovar reprova de cesa
enfeitando as bibliotecas e diplomas
sendo utilizados como marcas de grife ou
formei na grife tal
isso tudo me preocupa
isso tudo está gravando a gente pode
falar assim que muitas coisas mudaram
mas isso não é a regra
países como finlândia como cingapura
como coréia resolveram sim tornar isso
um padrão e mudaram o jeito que o ensino
básico pelo menos é feito mas cadê a
educação ea evolução dela em andragogia
no ensino de adultos na europa gojra ia
deixando que as pessoas criem se
os próprios caminhos e trilhas de
aprendizagem
isso tudo ainda está muito distante está
aumentando cada vez mais a preocupação
que a gente tem que ter em cima disso
hoje no brasil temos a maior geração de
nenên 11 milhões de jovens nem estudam
nem trabalham
temos uma um desemprego desenfreado de
quase 12 milhões de pessoas 90 por cento
dos que estão empregados são infelizes
no seu trabalho
hoje o brasil é o país mais ansioso do
mundo a gente vende mais livros rivotril
do que aspirina ea gente ainda tá
falando de setores que evoluem mas de
educação que ainda não se desenvolve e
pra mim isso é um problema e toda vez
que eu vejo um problema eu vejo três
portas à porta de quem reclama à porta
de quem sugere ea porta de quem resolve
eu gosto muito de como empreendedores
olham essas três filas que tá tá cheia
duas dessas filas
mas o empreendedor não gosta de fila
empreendedor vai transformar problema em
oportunidade ele vai naquela fila da
resolução e eu já estive nessa fila já
entrei por essa porta
estou no meu quarto cnpj e em todos
esses eu tive um padrão querer ajudar se
desenvolver como empreendedor aprender
com os meus erros aprender com os
fracassos que todas essas trilhas me
prepararam para estar onde hoje mas foi
uma pergunta que mudou completamente a
minha vida foi a pergunta mais difícil
que eu tive que responder quando um
mentor e me chamou e falou junqueira
como você quer morrer na hora eu
respondi cremado não afogado não
atropelado não ele não é isso mesmo
eu estou falando como você quer ser
lembrado no dia do seu caixão estiver
descendo como você quer que as pessoas
estejam ao seu redor
ou será que vai ter pessoas ao seu redor
mas o que de fato você vai deixar de
legado e aquilo foi como um soco no meu
estômago eu dei uma longa pausa
pensei refletir e responde eu quero ter
uma empresa de dia
e dá aula à noite eu quero ser um
empreendedor
eu quero ser um educador que entende que
essas duas palavrinhas mudam
completamente impactam positivamente
qualquer tipo de sociedade
empreendedorismo gerar emprego renda e
um inovações e transformações
tecnológicas e educação porque muda a
longo prazo porque as pessoas tomam suas
próprias decisões ninguém tira o
conhecimento que elas têm
e nada melhor do que juntar essas duas
coisas em uma só empreender em educação
e eu achei um problema para resolver
eu achei um problema quando eu descobri
que era muito difícil formar pessoas
para trabalhar no mercado de tecnologia
era muito difícil contratar pessoas
preparadas e eu descobri um dado que ano
que vem
em 2020 750 mil pessoas mil postos de
trabalho não serão ocupados por falta de
profissional em tecnologia e o que a
gente tem de solução que na teoria a
graduação para formar pessoas
qualificadas para o mercado de trabalho
essas universidades têm acumulado
prejuízo ano após ano por conta da
invasão só em 2017 foi 1.3 milhões de
pessoas que deixaram seus cursos
superiores
a gente não está formando mais a gente
não tá contratando os melhores
as empresas estão precisando de pessoas
que não são somente as pessoas que
trazem o aspecto técnico mas trazem o
comportamental eu descobri que os
talentos também não querem trabalhar mas
só por dinheiro quero propósito quer
autonomia eu quero flexibilidade
eu quero um ambiente onde um sinta que o
que eu estou fazendo também impacta
positivamente o mundo e por isso queria
marcar de uma escola de tecnologia que
forma pessoas para o mercado de trabalho
mas que forma pessoas acima de tudo eu
podia ficar falando aqui várias vezes
várias das coisas que a gente fez mas eu
queria falar de um desses programas gama
spears
a gente criou uma nova metodologia de
ensino completamente diferente que salva
e poupa tempo e dinheiro das pessoas
entregando uma experiência de
aprendizagem transformadora
só que com a união de empresas que nos
ajudam a fazer isso para você criar uma
educação
viva e formar pessoas que aprendem
rápido você precisa de ambiente e
formato ambiente porque eu tô falando de
criar um ambiente simulado e mercy vivo
e baseado em problemas
isso porque a gente criou o ambiente
simulado onde de fato eu entrego aspecto
significados aspectos que é de fato
fazem as pessoas se desenvolverem na sua
soft skills um programa e mercy vivo
significa que vão ser cinco meses em
cinco semanas que as pessoas vão se
desenvolver não só nas suas capacidades
técnicas mas também nas comportamentais
e baseado em problemas que eu vou ter
que simular a vida real eu vou ter que
trabalhar em menos tempo mais resultados
para conseguir entregar mas tudo isso só
é possível se eu tiver um bom formato e
um formato precisa de pessoas com uma
motivação intrínseca que faça umas às
outras a cauda beach que é uma certa
responsabilidade uma das outras uma
prestação de contas uma para as outras
durante um determinado tempo e com isso
modifica o jeito de aprendizagem e isso
traz não aluno não só alunos três fãs
para sua marca
pessoas que se sentem de fato
transformados e querem compartilhar isso
com o mundo e querem fazer disso o seu
ambiente e o seu propósito e isso gera
pra gente uma felicidade extrema que de
2016 para cá já foram mais de três mil
alunos com 90 por cento de
empregabilidade com mais de 90 de taxa
de satisfação e isso nos orgulha muito
por ter mais de 500 empresas junto com a
gente então funciona ou usar contra o
sistema ea gente só está nos dez minutos
de dois tempos de 45 porque a meta
transformar a vida de um milhão de
talentos através de educação e
tecnologia e isso é muito difícil mas é
mais fácil quando a gente conta com os
nossos alunos e fala a partir daqui é
com você você tem que fazer o bem também
queria uma corrente do bem vai lá ensina
mais três do que você aprendeu
independente de quem você é a gente dá
valor e quem você quer ser
e isso a gente aprendeu que tem que ser
feito de uma maneira é bem metodo
metódica e por isso eu queria
compartilhar com vocês a teoria das
conexões do eixo profissional temos
sempre três recursos escassos tempo
dinheiro e atenção tempo o que nos faz
exatamente igual ao bill gates
ele acorda com 24 horas você também a
quadra com 24 horas
dinheiro que nos faz também exatamente
diferente do bill redes
ele acorda bilionário a gente está na
luta e atenção é aquela possibilidade de
você tem acesso a pessoas que são
provavelmente inacessíveis
aquele fã aquele ídolo que você tem
aquela pessoa famosa que você gostaria
de ter uma pessoa da sua área que é uma
grande inspiração porque você não é
importante ainda suficiente para essa
pessoa do ao tempo dela pra te dar
atenção então a gente tem que saber aqui
a todo esse processo e do outro lado no
eixo pessoal
nós também temos o tempo o amor eo ea
morte porque nós temos que usar o nosso
tempo na terra pra dar e receber amor
das pessoas que a gente gosta porque a
gente teme e tem certeza da morte essas
são as abstrações da vida e se a gente
soma tudo isso a gente vê que um fator é
predominantes pessoas e tempo
são esses os fatores fundamentais pra
gente transformar o modelo de educação e
se você começar a me perguntar do futuro
essa metodologia vai para muitos lugares
recebemos vários contatos de pessoas
querendo implementar querendo fazer
também diferente
o que a gente fez simplesmente não
seguindo necessariamente as regras
eu diria mais eu quero fazer um uma
analogia de futuro com vocês imaginem
daqui 30 anos uma empresa chamada mãe de
história onde será possível você baixar
habilidades a um clique de distância
quer aprender um novo instrumento um
novo esporte uma nova língua eu vou
fazer o download assim como matrix
instalar na minha mente já saí
aprendendo e fazendo com que o
conhecimento seja compartilhado uma
pessoa no leito de morte pode se
transferir para as pessoas mais jovens
tudo que ela aprendeu e absorveu nossa
isso é muito bom aqui me rendi junqueira
sim eu escrevi em 2017
esse roteiro pro autor de black mirror
esse aqui é o e mail que eu mandei pra
ele nunca foi respondida mas aqui os
dias vai estar na telinha
mas independente se isso é possível ou
não se isso é é muito tópico autopia
serve pra gente andar porque cada vez
que a gente dá dois passos para frente
ela dá dois passos para trás e ela só
serve pra fazer a gente andar e andar
significa chegar lá ainda que 30 anos no
dia cinco do dez de 2049
e eu vou estar com 60 anos desse
jeitinho e o meu sonho é receber de um
aluno de um ex-aluno um vale presente da
mãe história que esse aluno terá criado
um futuro o tópico pra mim mas uma
verdade uma realidade e inevitavelmente
chegaremos nesse futuro utópico e que eu
vou ter muito orgulho de ter formado
alguém que vai ter criado esse futuro e
falar de futuro é falar de inspiração é
falar de outras pessoas que nos fazem
agir por terem coragem de ter feito lá
atrás como jobs como marie currie com
uma mala como doutor king pessoas que
sim transformaram o mundo mas eu tomei
uma decisão eu não quero transformar o
mundo
eu quero formar a próxima pessoa que vai
transformar muito obrigado
[Aplausos]